j'utilise toujours avec cette peine à
l'encontre du maire de monnaie le
tribunal correctionnel de Tours a décidé
cet après-midi de le condamner à un an
d'inel éligibilité et 7500 euros
d'amende sauf s'il fait appel
oliviermont va donc perdre son écharpe
de mer il était jugé pour prési légale
d'intérêt les explications de Florent
Clavel vous saviez parfaitement que ce
que vous y était illégal la présidente
de l'audience vient de faire voler en
éclat les derniers espoirs du maire
d'hiver droite de Monet Olivier viémond
qui avait plaidé la bonne foi lors de
son procès il y a dix jours en caisse
les lieux est déclarés coupables de
prise illégales d'intérêt les premiers
faits s'étale sur la période
2017-2020 des travaux d'assainissement à
Money une entreprise sous-traitante et
choisit c'est celle du maire c'est lui
qui apposera sa signature en 2018 cette
fois Olivier Vimond également à la tête
d'une SCI donne son accord pour un
permis de construire sur un bâtiment qui
lui appartient deuxième conflit
d'intérêt pris les mains dans le pot de
confiture selon sa propre expression
l'élu avait alors plaidé l'erreur
insuffisant donc pour les juges qui le
condamnent à une peine d'un an d'inel
éligibilité et 7500 euros d'amende le
maire et son avocat ton refusé de
répondre à nos questions en revanche le
chef de l'opposition modéienne lui ne
s'en prive pas c'est en effet Jean-Marc
schnell qui avait révélé l'affaire pour
moi la dernière élection municipale
s'est faite en partie sur un mensonge
parce qu'on peut considérer quand même
que si il avait fait état aux électeurs
de la situation réelle
le résultat n'aurait pas été le même la
campagne n'aurait pas été la même et
donc à partir de là il me semble que la
meilleure solution effectivement c'est
cette démissionner le maire de monnaie a
maintenant 10 jours pour faire appel
faute de quoi elle devra démissionner de
son mandat c'est alors son premier
adjoint qui assurera l'intérim